[Music]
[Applause]
all right for the record but already
been a little too nice to y'all now that
our pricing on snake guys will face for
your shoulders oh I see y'all 86 party
hey I won't get a bar today
their luncheon the polonaise I'm
flipping the ball breaking ball breaking
time still can't win when a daddy
already already I let him take advantage
of swelling ball wrecking all friggin
Dale's telling truck the colors for the
phone all breaking off record I still
went to act not the coast butter running
don't try and make ya'll comfortable for
the record you ain't right well then
start with you
for the record
we go all the way
for the record ain't no China wish run
it do it with the yellow inside that
lesson presents us a comment so wait up
and give me guess this one a shame the
way that complete the checkered but the
boots are looser than a pail even better
still go for some I can work on Windows
when I loses any losses cuz I had the
Fitbit shoot me number zookas for the
facts I need fast [ __ ] attacks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I ran up a check on my do it again and
the Me's closed had me thinking they're
friends
ten toes down I'll be fitting to the end
curb outside the city I don't fit if in
my ears took so many years I'll just
wait for the West I'm in debt to norm
but the one eats of my says I do it for
real it's no reason to pretend if I do
it again
[Music]
bankrolling
I just told me everything's on me oh you
matter what told it it's all me
everything is on me going back it up
told y'all I'm gonna do me while you
hating on me it's not enough
I do roll like a Mack truck come to
heart I'm a cup of farm and go egg cup
lot of scars I was cold hearted I'm back
keep it real I do this once a month much
just take the money Engel stack up car
cards they can set it up another bullet
don't matter much let me climb me I put
the letters up no fault
I don't doubled up on the workload I
think I fell in love with the bankroll
pray I'll give money then we lay low
then we lay low
[Music]
me Oh you matter what's on me to do me
why you hating on me to do me well you
know me
[Music]
they got presents or parents or parents
or pilots on pylons on pylons I saw by
my brother no money depressive eCollege
for my blessings I'm pulling the birdie
is back tell me I'm prophets I'm
deciding that's why I call it own
impression the song as I wanted the for
win affection at something in public
thank our parents on pylons on brothers
and brothers or parents or brothers I
saw them I run to the money depressor be
calling for my blessings I feel like I'm
pulling the birdie is back tell me I'm
promise I'm going to sign that's why I
call it learning progression is solid I
wanted a for win affection I summoned of
it why you love my line about nothing
why won't you go get you with other
Simpson d'oh hang with it love for
nothing I see that we differ you rising
that double my don't do discussions I'm
dragging my hunting so hold your places
I know they say something so homey
you're probably too trusting my dollars
on coping so hand me the money I give me
the pie imma give all of my people are
pushing to put them a fortune on pep in
the broth
I can't mix he went to feeder bar before
you Padilla's related job
why are you rolling my phone like you
was in the mix is a mission that no
other mission I needed some personal
challenges I mean it I'm staying inside
take a connoisseur parents or parents or
parents or present some problems I saw
by my brother the money the pressure we
call it my blessings
I'm pullin 2:30 is back tell me I'm
Papi's I'm coming to sign that's why I
call it bone impression the solid I
wanted the for win affection and
something in public this checkup eleazar
eleazar eleazar eleazar eleazar eleazar
solver my run through the money
depressive we call it that for my
blessings I feel like I'm calling the 30
is back tell me I'm Papa's I'm [ __ ]
deciding that's why I call it bone and
progression is solid young hitter got a
fetish for success of finding next ni
da' sleeping pressure next to brain on
the windowpane put the Plain Jane let
him second-guess me want a cup of pores
with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome everyone thank
you so much for joining us today
my name is Felicia Kelly I want to
welcome you to a Juneteenth celebration
hosted by Bleacher Report and the black
Alliance network I'm super excited for
today in our event today's event is
hosted again by Bleacher poor and band
and we're going through this work in
progress and today's event is hosted
again by bleat report and black employee
which is which reports black employee
resource group titled embrace if you
don't know about embrace embrace offers
black employees of bleach report a
chance to build community within the
organization facilitate professional
development create opportunities for
philanthropy through VR we're really an
organization that's trying to amplify
black voices you can follow us on social
zon twitter linkedin and instagram at be
our embrace i want to do a special
shout-out to Effie Lauren and Rachel for
helping me hold this down this event and
actually make this happen but we weren't
alone we also partnered with our sisters
at van the black lions Network um if you
don't know about van van also does
something very similar to bleach report
and that they are a diverse talent a
group from vsi's global black employee
resource group and
again we all about professional
development enhancing industry knowledge
networking and really growth and
retention of black employees across the
industry we work in sports now but I
know having worked in media and music we
all are story creators so we're really
about amplifying our voices and writing
together so shout outs and Natasha
afarid aja Imani and Shanae again thank
you ladies because it's been a hard few
weeks but we put it together so I'm very
very proud to be a part of this today
today is a celebration it's been again
crazy few weeks but I really want to use
today to celebrate um so the first part
of the event is going to be a panel
discussion to educate and first all to
be more informed and we have a really
dope lineup of people that are going to
talk and have a dialogue what's going on
in sports and then immediately after
this we're going to celebrate with a
virtual mixer I do have a few reminders
if you RSVP'd for the event and plan on
going to the mixer after this please go
to your vampire link and click the zoom
link the breakout rooms are going to be
separated into about 10 to 15 people
each and it'll be a networking hour it's
supposed to be super fun good way for
you to meet people from the event um and
if you are planning to go to the event
the biggest thing is for you to click
the zoom link now it's just going to
make our transition to the after party
that much easier you can put yourself on
you turn off your mic but it's like
waiting in line for the party we're
really trying to make this easier for
you and you don't want you standing
outside another reminder is just don't
forget to fill out the survey at the end
that's in the Eventbrite we really want
your feedback again this is our first
event but we want to grow and learn from
it so any feedback or comments that you
have from us please let us know if you
want to engage in the conversation
please make sure to sign in to your
YouTube channel to participate in the
comments and the chat section and if
you're having any issues you can log
into your Google account again this is a
dialog it's not just between the
panelists we want you to share on social
you can follow embrace at embrace or
cross so shows as well as banne at black
Alliance Network and the hashtag for
today is embrace Juneteenth w van
with the fist emoji so without further
ado I'm gonna kick it off to mark Lamont
Hill to start our panel and discussion
and happy juicing teeth
good afternoon good afternoon everybody
happy Juneteenth my name is Mark Lamont
Hill I am the host of BT news and I am
excited to be a part of each report at
Alliance networks Juneteenth event we
have an amazing panel today with some of
the most interesting people and some of
the you know some of the most I would
say active people in the world right now
and across a range of fields I want to
introduce the panel so you can hear
about them from them
I have Tara August she is the senior
vice president of talent relations and
special projects at Turner Sports and
bleacher report she oversees the on-air
talent across the digital and the linear
networks she is responsible for Shaq
sparkly deep rain she's the woman behind
the scenes and and she does so much more
than I just said but let's give her a
welcome anyway and she'll tell you
something awesome I love my lord I know
there's clapping but that's my little
Oprah clap we got Kia Clark in his third
season as chief operating officer of the
New York Liberty she oversees the
business planning budget and operations
for the team and this is her 10th season
working with the Liberty welcome Kia
Thank You Maya and we're also joined by
Caron Butler he is a former professional
basketball player he's a two-time NBA
all-star he's the Big East Player of the
Year he in 2015 he wrote a book which I
really enjoy tough juice my journey from
the streets to the NBA and my favorite
thing about him and honestly the only
thing that allows me to root for him
despite never playing for the Sixers is
the fact that he has been on the streets
as as an activist participating in these
protests and doing what so many people
don't do which is taking his words and
putting them to action welcome Quran
so let's start off by talking about
Juneteenth I just want to set the table
quick because you know for a lot of
people
Juneteenth is something that they didn't
even know about even even a week ago or
two weeks ago up until a president Trump
plan that rally on the 19th initially a
lot of people didn't know what
Juneteenth was but for those that don't
know and it's okay if you didn't know
Juneteenth is you know marks the moment
were slave enslaved Africans in Texas in
1965 finally received word that they
were free and of course and a half years
after the Emancipation Proclamation and
it's a - it's a Chisholm it's a
statewide holiday in Texas but it's
something that black folk around the
country have increasingly acknowledged
and part of why we acknowledge is
because July 4 1776 ain't our Freedom
Day
that's not our Independence Day our
Independence Day comes much later and so
this idea of unrealized freedom this
idea that freedom is not done and that
our justice and our freedom was delayed
it wasn't denied but it was delayed in
many ways speaks to what I want to talk
to y'all about today this idea that we
still got work to do and the last couple
of weeks
oh the last couple of weeks has shown us
the type of work that we have to do what
do you all make of some of the events
that have taken place in the last month
from George Floyd to Brianna Taylor what
do you make of everything well I'll jump
in and just thank you today for putting
it together today it's just you know
it's another reason to celebrate and be
celebrated to amplify our voices so
kudos to everyone who is joining that
now but to your point to your question
mark all the recent events are and
you've heard this over over again are
the thing that we've known for so long
we've been coming to work with a
struggle on our minds and the pressure
of seeing our black brothers and sisters
being killed and being threatened and
living it every day the recent events
have just spotlighted for the world
nothing
you know we've been talking about those
in discussions for weeks now but all
that the recent it became a tipping
point we're now the world even outside
of America to finally join us in the
pressure the sadness the pain and then
hopefully the action absolutely yeah
also mark this me I think has been a
informing time for numerous reasons
because you know I always questioned the
realness of what I was being educated on
from educational system in the school
but then also in my household with my
grandparents my mom and everyone that
migrated from south grew up in Columbus
Mississippi agreement worked on the
cotton fields and they always told me
that you know Jill team dishes you know
our proclamation our celebration our
industry and then we came up here and a
predominantly white state in Wisconsin
and we had to gather research you
celebrate this day so we had stage on
will we had to gather the community to
bring out the the cultural food you know
the black business all those angles
highlighted and when I was in school it
was just like it doesn't is it the
teacher name was Miss I li get I was
like fuel team they're real thing she
was like it's not in the history book
it's not here like you know and I wasn't
you know it was just like a crazy
talents so now being a father I go out
my way it's been point of emphasis to
educate our children about the
importance of knowing one our history in
our culture and now this time is just
like a explosion of energy that's
trending you know fortunately in our in
our and our favor you know for the first
time ever centuries Pike is Trenton in
our favor and it's a great time to have
platforms like this Thank You Tara said
this educate and inform and I think this
is really I think this really dope yeah
similar to what Quran said you know it's
it's an inspiring time
I think a lot of us around the world
felt like here we go again
but instead it's been kind of
kick-started into action and you know
the people who don't know I think are
reading and educating themselves and
trying to understand in a way that maybe
it hasn't been you know that that type
of effort before so you know I'm hopeful
but like I said I'm incredibly inspired
by this time I know there's a lot of
emotions initially that you know people
felt but it's sort of metamorphosed into
this you know how do we come together
how do we move forward can I can I ask
and I'm just curious out of you know the
four of us at work where any of us
thought about black Wall Street and the
massacre in Tulsa when we were growing
up I mean that was also something that
was a prevalent history I know I know
that I wasn't is it at a young age I
wasn't yeah everything about our history
I had a dream for myself
nothing educationally nothing in the
school system honestly I didn't know
about Juneteenth until I got to college
you know I just happened to be in
Buffalo and stumbled upon a gteen
festival but you know I educated myself
obviously over time and it's just great
to see you know more and more people
doing that my granddad was one day used
to sit around and tell me about you know
black businessmen and how we had our own
banks and how we had our own resources
you know Wall Street and I just thought
it didn't exist I heard the stories and
he told me a lot of stories he told me a
lot of things and he informed me at a
young age but I just didn't know it was
an actual reality until I you know start
getting older and start seeing visuals
I'll never forget the History Channel
had did a special and they showed like
the actual visual of black Wall Street
and the fires and everything that
happened and I was like whoa man oh man
they lose it he was telling the truth
you know me and I he's putting me up a
game you know like brother hang really
Rock I don't know horses putting you
know get jumping off and handling the
jib business man like it was just it was
so empowering
I just started informing myself even
more after that point I'm glad you said
that because that all of you said that
it has a great point because so much and
by the way Russell Westbrook is
executive producing a film on on always
talking about in terms of Tulsa and
black Wall Street and so I think that
that's another opportunity for another
generation of people to need access to
information that we didn't have access
to because when we were coming up again
so much of our history begins and ends
with slavery and it always positions
black people as objects in history and
not subjects in history you know we get
free when Lincoln frees us we become you
know we get the right to vote when when
Lyndon Johnson signs a bill and it
doesn't tell the story of what we did
for ourselves it doesn't tell the story
of the history that we had that doesn't
begin with slavery but that was
interrupted by slavery and it doesn't
tell the story of all the possibilities
that we have based on what we've already
done I think that's why Juneteenth is
also an important opportunity here to
educate ourselves and to educate of non
black people that we have a history that
doesn't have slave that's what high
school I used to always tell my students
I tell my students in college now you
know slaves weren't brought to America
people were and just when you make that
distinction by saying slaves were
brought here people were and they were
enslaved
it allows you to see them in a whole
different light and until a whole
different story um do you feel
optimistic about sort of where we're
going in terms of what we're educating
the public about that now people have
more knowledge about black folk in our
culture and our history than we did even
when we were coming up through high
school personally I'm hopeful you know I
think time will tell it we're gonna have
to be patient in some respects and then
also demand that things happen
immediately I'm hopeful I'm always gonna
have faith I think we can all agree that
we've never seen it at this point we've
never seen it be okay to publicly come
out and address the black community in a
corporate statement in in corporate
conversation so things are opening up
but we're going to have to keep holding
people accountable to see really
we'll be sustainable change and that's
that's where the rub is I love that
we're telling stories differently I love
that we're finding out into your point
mark like kids that are growing up now
gonna have access to this history that
when we were younger people pretend it
didn't exist or wasn't important enough
to tell the Tulsa example if anybody's
an HBO watcher a Watchmen fan they did
such an amazing job with that last
season of incorporating that into this
sci-fi storyline I mean just smart just
a way to talk about things that were
real and unreal together jointly and
with the black female lead and that that
series did so many important things in
an entertaining way but that gives me
hope that Hollywood for all of its
issues people are breaking through and
being able to tell stories and to
spotlight us differently than just
always doing you know on the on the
undercard again we'd like you please
check I was gonna say I certainly hope
the curiosity you know continues and
extends as Tara said it's like when my
kids are walking up to me saying you
know they're talking about June teens on
Nickelodeon right now or you know this
is the prolific manner in which social
media and everyone can have a place in
this space
I hope I'm very hopeful I agree that you
know it would just continue in the more
you you've learned the more you want to
learn you want to dig into other stories
and really have a better understanding
of our people our experience part of why
this country is going through the kind
of up people were saying part of why
we're seeing so much energy on the
street part of why were seeing these
corporate responses is because of the
death of George Floyd and of course I
want to acknowledge the death of Brianna
Taylor I want to acknowledge the death
of a Matar Bri I would acknowledge the
death of so many people who tragically
had their lives loss in ways that just
simply should not have Rashard Brooks
last week all these deaths but George
Floyd seemed to be a turning point for
the country when we saw that videotape
of him with the officers need that Derek
show hands knee on his neck America
responded we took to the streets we saw
so much why do you think that
moment was so we've seen lots of death
worldwide that moment well I mean me
personally at visual was just you know
heartbreaking and terrified to watch it
it was a visual that was shared
immediately that we we we've met custom
to hearing and seeing or having
conversations about things like past and
it's in things just as harsh when you
think about image or in all these
situations but this visual and the
optics of it you know it was a universal
wrong every you know to me and I think
that people from all walks of life
disagree for once you know in the midst
of the pandemic you know what I mean it
was this nowhere you run it it was
nowhere that you can skate like whether
it was live entertainment or anything
you had to really deal with this reality
on where we are at as a society
obviously we got a lot of stuff
politically we got to deal with an
author other stuff but this was just
like yo the empathy as a human being to
see this happen
it was just like everybody had to get
engaged and what I was really moved by
is that it wasn't just black and brown
people it wasn't just a Latin X
community it was white folks as well and
when I saw the individuals of the front
line Minnie Annapolis and then even when
we was marching in Los Angeles even when
you seen state estate in all 50 states
in over 18 countries that's what I was
moved by because people said you know
what this invisible racism and these
social injustice that continued to get
swept under the rug and trauma that we
know that it insists and we're not
identifying trauma and address will
continue to hurt people and we have to
address the fact that we have systemic
issues and what do we need to do to
expedite the bills and laws to get
passed so we can change some of these
outcomes because brown mark we all know
every three seconds in America someone s
have may encounter with law enforcement
and this is starting to become a trend
right so that's all for
14.5 4.6 billion a year that's a large
number so it could possibly be getting
more Jorge floors I might operate
situations just with law enforcement in
that space so if we don't act and act
accordingly
this can be devastating for us going
forward if I can add to that too I mean
anything Curran you're spot-on about you
know everyone saw the tape and it's one
of the instances we've seen other things
on tape but if this is one of the
instances where we had the full complete
picture we saw it from various angles we
saw various people police officers being
involved we saw bystanders crying out
saying this is not okay so it was it had
all of these elements all these
different touch points that made you say
I can't ignore it I can't say well you
can't really tell or the report didn't
show this we had everything that we
needed to say if you're a human you have
to pay attention to this injustice I'd
also add and remember the timing we're
all coming out of quarantine and kovat
and in this place of not being able to
operate under normal life and hopefully
coming through a point of introspection
because we spent time alone or we spent
time with our family members or without
our family members so it came at a time
that we were all changed already and we
had the attention of the world because
everybody didn't have their normal
distractions so I think that that adds
to the layer of why people pay attention
inside and didn't just say it was just
another news headline didn't have time
to get involved but they saw it and they
had to deal with it and our feelings
were all in a different space that
because of what we had all just gone
through you know globally with the
pandemic there is in chaos I start with
you on this question there there's also
a response not just from everyday people
who took to the streets but also
athletes you know I mean one of the
first people at the front line of course
was Stephen Jackson who was personally
connected to to the incident him having
a relationship a very close relationship
with George Floyd but it wasn't just it
wasn't just him it was people who I
normally don't hear from on
street it was people who are always here
from on the street and I'm talking about
athletes right now it hasn't seemed to
have really stepped up in this moment
now of course as we said Kovac creates
some of that context because there were
no games but they could've been doing a
whole lot other stuff other than taking
to the streets what what what do you see
from athletes right now you know in
terms of the response to everything
going on in the world yeah you know I
think athletes and especially the
high-profile ones understand their
influence and you know the range of
people that they they have a reach to
but in that moment and in these moments
that continue to persist they're looking
at these folks as regular people you
know that is that would be my brother my
cousin my father
it's the realness and you know kind of
it brings it home back to you know maybe
it's not the wealthiest person it's not
the entertainer it's not the athlete but
that could be anyone that I love and so
those who are using their voices and
know that they have influence and know
that they can you know incite other
people to make a difference and to
really use their voices as well I think
that's why we see a lot of that
particularly you know and I'll speak for
the WNBA and and the Liberty
Organization there had been some
protesting that began four years ago you
know when when falando Cassio and Elton
sterling were killed were murdered a lot
of the teams got together and they you
know kind of band it together
and instead you know we want to use our
platform so I think there are moments
that are more incendiary than others but
for that for that case you know athletes
understand what their platform means you
know and what their voice means to the
greater population but I really do think
it's just the the realness of this could
be anyone of you know the people that I
love it just to echo what you said yeah
Steven J actually reached out in real
time this incident happened not only
this could be someone that ever had a
personal connection with but you took it
a step
earlier instead this was my brother this
one this was my [ __ ] was my you know
never to have that connection with mixed
result and that's why people move you
know Stephen Jackson personally wish to
his entire circuit his entire network to
say new job worn out and have them ever
we all rallied round I think that that's
how the needle was moved to bring it you
know to work out this I'm proud of you
know you know because really took the
leadership role and making sure that
this was not gonna get swept under the
rug so you know biggest captain Jackson
tremendous Crump's every sport but he
brought up such a great point that WNBA
players took a stand long ago and showed
supported games and you know you'd be
remiss not to spotlight players that
have paid the biggest sacrifice Maya
Moore and Kaepernick certainly who were
fighting or calling it for attention
long ago before when we all supported
them but we weren't marching in the
streets or we weren't speaking out about
it at work and they were doing it very
early on and that just has had such an
important impact now I'm glad I'm glad
you mentioned Maya Moore because you
know so often we celebrate male athletes
who do this and when you talk about
progressive athletic voices the WNBA has
been extremely progressive in many ways
more progressive than other professional
sports leagues across the board and
someone like Maya Moore has made such
extraordinary sacrifices to I mean we're
talking we're talking about someone some
of them to Muhammad Ali is a good
account example because you tell me
someone who at that peak of their talent
someone who has the ability to still
perform at a high level is willing to
make a sacrifice of their career for
something bigger than them that that's
something extraordinary and something
that we often don't get acknowledged
from about athletes my question is you
know against the backdrop of that there
are people who keep saying athletes
shouldn't be doing this the athlete
should focus on sport there's some folk
we won't say who they are
they shut up and dribble and so all of
that stuff happening what do you make of
that of that atmosphere where athletes
are being pulled in certain directions
they're being told to just play the
sport don't say they don't say this
don't say that
what do you make of you know I work with
you know the most famous and biggest
person who said that he was not a role
model right so to me it's about being
your authentic self and for Charles that
always meant the role models are the
heroes that we see in the streets and in
the schools and you know don't don't
define yourself by what an athlete says
or does however we do look to them for
guidance but to me it's about being
authentic so I would never expect or put
somebody in a place to say you have to
be a vocal part of this fight you know I
watched Dave Chappelle's special and he
talked a little bit about why he decided
to finally speak out and not being
called out and I think it's personal and
you know working closely like we all do
with with celebrities and entertainment
or sports there's a lot of work to be
done quietly too so if it's not on your
heart to speak out vocally and verbally
and with symbol and certainly by God do
do the work privately amongst or circle
or support organizations that do
absolutely Quran let me ask you a
question about this because so there's
the people who say athletes you need to
be speaking out I hear that right and
people find that lame but what about the
people to say y'all shouldn't be talking
I want you to work on that jump shot and
did if there's a break I don't need you
talking about Kobe 19 or police violence
well the best you know with his phrase
you got to give him a ton of credit
about the same more than athletes
I think that you know we are so many
other things you know we are community
leaders we are you know entrepreneurs
we're husbands we're fathers were proud
you know kids you know in our respective
spaces and you know to people that tell
you that they understand that you have
real authentic influence and that is a
threat to a lot of people because if you
can move the needle if you could you
know sway in half you know the following
of yours you know tap into and be
informed and educated on
some of the solution justices and things
that's happening in real time that that
is scary and people don't want you to be
in that space you know telling the
reality and shoot straight from you know
what I mean so I I've been in his face
for quite over twenty years now I'm so
glad that the young athletes are making
it their priority in the midst of the
height of their career to continue to
move the needle and keep that getup
going so you know bigger call to young
guys that take the stance on social
injustice and all the injustice is that
they happening and they respect the
space and making it known they're
speaking louder on it on their platforms
that's so important kill who do you see
particularly what athletes are you
singing and this is for oliver's
monastiraki who are you seeing out there
that's really making you proud at the
way they're using their voice not just
that this month but in general yeah I'm
incredibly biased obviously because of
the work that I knew but I have to say
you know especially because our women
aren't always in market they play
overseas they play in the United States
they're often not together but to see
just folks popping up everywhere
in the United States and abroad and
really continuing to come together
continue to stay in communication so
that their voices can be louder together
I have to say that I'm incredibly biased
to delete that I work it I work with
specifically again the liberty and I'm
not trying to toot a horn here but in
when that incident and those incidents
happen in 2016 the players and it's a
much different team now but at that time
you know it was swin cash you know it
was Tina Charles and they they looked at
the organization and said we want to
continue to do this this is not you know
a one-time thing and we don't want to
you know yelling screaming holler just
one time we want this work to continue
so I think it's that commitment and you
know the longevity of using your
platform that really is more impactful
and
meaningful so you know I'm incredibly
proud of the women in this league I'd
have to say I think the legends like
Kareem abdul-jabbar he's done the great
work in his generation and continues to
be an inspiration today so some of the
young guys absolutely they're just
getting separated here's their voices
but we've got you know a legend around
who still gives us some inspiration
Kareem is a great when I'm a real
long-distance runner when it comes to
this stuff my him Bill Russell and
that's an area of social justice also
about the question of justice for
athlete being able to be a free agent
being able to advocate for yourself
being able to advocate think about
someone like Craig Hodges who was
advocating for you know more black
coaches and for and for black sort of
collective wealth in inside and outside
of the league people who pay prices for
this type of stuff I want to take a step
back and ask you all about sort of how
you all navigate these spaces as
professionals because another thing that
we've had space to talk about do to
covet and these uprisings it's sort of
how black people navigate the world in
general you know how we navigate our
professional circles how has it been as
very successful black people navigating
your professional networks how do you do
it what are some of the challenges that
you should that you that you face I'm
gonna start with you on this because you
what I feel you got some good some good
insight as the SVP you know talking
about even to get there I mean you've
had to navigate a space that put a bunch
of people that don't look like you we
all have had to do that in some form or
fashion how do you do it um you know pun
intended but I'd always embraced it
right so from the beginning when I knew
I wanted to work in sports and when I
was in college and you know trying to
graduate and trying to hustle and cobble
together enough experience to get my
foot in the door I knew that I was a you
know
corne just because I was a woman and
just because I was black naughty
unicorns I was smarter than anybody else
might not even really been different
than anybody else I just knew I was
going to be the only one in the room so
I was very comfortable just
acknowledging it and owning it I've said
for a long time finding a uniform
unicorn but I'm gonna put on a show so
I'm gonna be in a meeting I'm gonna be
prepared I'm always gonna ask a question
I'm gonna do follow-up like they're
gonna be paying attention to me I don't
want them to walk away I mean like yeah
I knew she didn't belong there like oh
snap she came ready or you know what she
was direct about being comfortable or
introducing herself so it is tricky
navigate and we all know this is like
people you wear your blackness first
before you they ask you about your
credentials or your experience so they
see me as a black woman first oftentimes
because I am the only one and then also
in the sports industry because there's
not there's not a whole lot of us
certainly Kia myself I think we're
working hard to you know stay on the
shoulders of other women and pull other
people up with us but when you're put in
a position this way it would be you
wouldn't be honest to say that there
isn't a finesse that you have to
navigate it because we're used to
conversations that people are
uncomfortable with when we try to
spotlight a black athlete or we try to
provide insights of not being
comfortable with a narrative of a news
story a sports story and being that so
that lone voice at time and knowing that
you know what you might be labeled the
difficult person because you keep saying
this is not right on the mark but now
that we have their ear and we have the
respect and the experience like now's
the time for us to not walk through the
door but Robby through it and take
advantage of now is the time they're
gonna be listening to the things that
we've been communicating for decades
yeah yeah I would add you know I have
the benefit I think of working in a
league that is made up predominantly of
black women and a lot of times that
navigation I can kind of use the product
as the demonstration of how things can
be handled in a lot of regard I mean
this is being broadcast oh yeah making
me give away two secrets right now but
it's like you know how the DNA of the
team is built what the brand values are
you know those things can so closely
mirror the things that would be
important to the athletes and you know
it is authentic becoming from me as a
black woman but I think that it would
authenticate by the folks who who play
the game so that's one of the reasons
why I really prefer and enjoy working in
the women's league and in Tara hit the
nail on the head where you know it's not
just being black in corporate America
but also being a woman so it's it's that
intersection that I'm kind of nestled in
this wheelhouse if you will if you will
and then you know there are times when
obviously I'm amount of boundaries and
that's where working hard and
preparedness and willingness and all of
those you know things that we just have
to do to maintain you know your ability
to perform well at all cost comes in but
you know I think it's a little bit
different in that I'm working with
people who look like me by and large
separately the team and the people that
I've hired people who work with me my
colleagues we've been very deliberate
about diverse and I think that matters
within companies too so that you're not
always the only one you know there could
be other voices sitting at the table
with you and you know sometimes not in
their heads yes and sometimes how in a
spirited conversation and checking you
but you know the more that we can grow
you know so we're not the unicorn in the
room the better come on how for you it's
interesting because again you're
surrounded by people who look like you
on the court as a player but then the
executive level is different the
coaching network is different and then
every other aspect of business and life
you know there are a whole bunch of
people who don't look like you who may
have different expectations about who
you are based on the fact that you're a
young black man and an athlete how do
you navigate their course the general
prepared a lot for real world
make the transition opposite because it
teach you want to be a star on your team
or a major supporter or you know just to
do dog movie like the weird you know
mean the best part of the portraits so
the thing that I was fortunate to have
was people troop out
so when I made this English transition
away came about the corporate you know
the biggest hurdle that I had was just
one being a black man and trying to you
know crowdfunding or anything you know
with my jokes come or not too much for
this particular [ __ ] why on the data
reference point or whenever I was about
to kill and happy movie investment and
you know so long this identified you as
that you know that whatever it was like
that the former basketball player former
soccer player baseball whatever the case
and you know that is a play that's a
that's a stereotype in its own right
there just being fat and you know I have
always tried to go above and beyond it
you want to over in for myself and do my
due diligence and just be the best in my
space you know so whether it was no
franchise in or whatever the case you
know I always wanted to over in fill in
that area so like to Tara Tara spoink
where she said you know what navigate
through that space it kind of does it
takes on the life to know I don't I'm
like I can't even give you the blueprint
to it it's just like it's a certain of
instinct its distinctive part of the
fight I feel I got occurred up a little
bit because they wanted you know what a
mission and I got to do it to death they
think I can't you know what I mean
because I don't even explain it but you
know in a filter and you know when we
think about in part part of what green
team is is an opportunity to meditate on
freedom you know what freedom look like
you know we come at a
traditional people who were enslaved and
had to imagine a world that was not yet
and some of them had to imagine that
world not for themselves but for their
children or their children's children
they were fighting for something
wouldn't even see so freedom was
abstract freedom was distant it was real
innocence they knew they get it but they
had no idea exactly what it would look
like we have the benefit of much of
their work in their struggle and we have
a lot more proximity to freedom than
they did so I say that so that I can ask
you on the spot you know what is what
what does freedom inequality look like
for us you know when you think about
what freedom will look like from where
we are now to where the end goal is
whatever that is what what what does it
look like to you what does freedom look
and feel like to you often yeah I
challenge that you know it starts with
the simple things that the four of us
know and certainly you know the black
community is not living in here you know
being racially profiled is just a basic
thing that we live with and to be able
to raise kids and have the back be
removed I mean it makes me emotional
just to think about it because certainly
every black man that I've ever known in
my entire life and my father to my
brother and Beyond have always had that
in the back of their minds not just a
reality so if we can ever get out of
that burden to me that would be enormous
you know certainly freedom to not have
to be to be unapologetically black
professionally now or personally because
there used to be a line like you don't
talk about race at this in business you
don't cross those lines you don't break
it there it's not appropriate now it can
be appropriate you can say black lives
matter and be proud of that we're
something be proud of that care that
something just happened in the news and
say you know what I'm dealing with
you know something that's weighing on me
emotionally to me that those are those
are small freedoms that would make an
enormous amount of difference I think I
would say and I'd agree it's a long list
of don't call them small but just beasts
human needs things that we should have
quite frankly already but if I could
summarize it I would say it's all of
those things that I wished I didn't have
to teach my children I have two kids
they're six and they're 80 I've already
had to have more conversations than I
thought I would have serious
conversations when you talk about the
talk and explaining racism and
explaining what happened to George Floyd
and exclaiming why my reprints you know
for hours and hours before she goes into
it me you know it's like if everything
is working together it's black text and
it's you must get an education you know
it's all of those things work together
but if there were you know just a moment
where my kids were kids and I didn't
have to have you know figure out ways to
have deep conversations with them that
would really be freedom because it would
really mean we've achieved ultimate
equality kids echo what you just said
sum it up for the things that white
America get immediately but I have this
simple is that in the notes field you
know the same opportunities that paint
Stander's even playing field I gotta
fight for did you know that's not
equality and I think that that's the
standard that's that's the narrative
that we try to change I was a Jane
Elliott the the you know race researcher
and she's done great things but she said
something so simple once to a crowd of
white people have raise your hand if
right now you would change place to
change places with a black person and
nobody raised their hands and she said
that's because you know that what's
happening and it's not okay for that
experience and why are you okay that it
happened to them it's not okay for you
it's very simple so if you wouldn't you
know change color lines or don't want
something for yourself somebody else's
experience for yourself that tells you
your your way
but there's an issue right and and if
you're aware of it you have a
responsibility to address it and to
change it and if you benefit from the
unequal arrangement of power then you
absolutely have an ethical and moral
duty to do something about it not just
white people but men but straight folk
but the wealth if all of us have this
name a cisgender folk we all have the
same responsibilities and I'm so honored
to be here talking to you all about what
those responsibilities are and where we
are at the moment and I only have about
a minute left but I wanted to ask you
what makes you hopeful will give you
hope to me personally I'm interested to
see hunter for the first time all life
being paid and now corporate is making
business and not only you know faces out
but capital and be just as grand and a
half because now brown and I'm a long
way I think for we what are some real
real deal so we can have those big
capital well and have real financial
exchange that's actually and I think
that'll be the last word just because
we're out of time but but really we
dreamed so deeply and so beautifully and
so ambitiously for hundreds of years and
we are the beneficiaries of the work of
people who did so much more with so much
less so we have nothing but a
responsibility right now to carry the
legacy on and all the work that we do
I'm so honored to talk to the three of
you because you all model that tradition
and that love of us and that commitment
to being the best self that we can be
and building the best community that we
can build so Caron Butler Kia Clarke
Tara August thank you so much for
joining me and I encourage everyone to
head over to the networking party we did
so
heavy stuff here and some good stuff but
now it's time to network in to talk so
if you RFP you can go over to the zoom
and you can be part of that conversation
too again thank you and happy June team
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
for the regular put already been a
little too late CR now got our price to
go snake eyes will dice for y'all Chozen
so I see y'all 86 party hey I won't get
involved today got lunch in the barman a
wrecking ball wrecking I still can't win
money
daddy all breaking ball breaking I let
him take advantage I was wiling ball
breaking ball breaking dales tell him
truck the color for the phone all
breaking all record I still went to act
like the coast but already done trying
to make y'all comfortable for the record
doing stuff with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I ran up a check on my do it again and
the Me's closed had me thinking they're
friends ten toes down I'll be freeing to
the end curve outside the city I don't
fit if in my ears took so many years I'm
this way for the whiz I'm in debt to
norm but the running time I says I do it
for real there's no reason to pretend if
I do it again
added up bankrolling
I'll add it up told me